the last time that I sat down and just
made a video where I'm just speaking to
the camera about a video game TV show
adaptation
it went very differently to how this one
is going to go the last one was Halo I'm
such a big halo fan and because I felt
like the HALO Series was so awful I
think I was still just trying to temper
my expectations when it came to The Last
of Us TV show I was still trying to be
like listen it all sounds good in theory
but what if you did that
the good news everybody is that I
uh seemingly alongside pretty much
everybody else that I've seen think that
the first episode of HBO's The Last of
Us TV show is fantastic I thought it was
brilliant and I have a plan for covering
every episode going forward obviously we
keep talking about it on playwatch
listen of course if you don't know that
that's my podcast with Troy Baker who
plays Joel In The Last of Us the game
that is it's weird that we now have to
differentiate those two things we've
spoken about that two weeks in a row I
imagine it'll keep coming up but I'm
actually planning to every week do a
live stream on Monday nights with a
different series of guests to talk about
the most recent episode of the show I
skipped this week uh because it's the
premiere I did have some guests locked
in who canceled and then I was like let
me just change things around so we'll
start streaming next week Monday 6 PM PT
so we can interact with you guys in the
live chat and talk about each episode a
day after the show comes out so very
excited to do that but for this one I
just wanted to sit down and talk about
my impressions of the first episode solo
first I felt like it was pretty clear
initially that it's not just going to be
a one-to-one adaptation of the games
which is awesome that's always a thing
that I'm like why do this other than for
new audiences which I get it's such a
good video game story The Last of Us is
such a good story I do think it's one of
the best stories told in video games and
so I definitely had this thing where I
was like I've already experienced this
and I've experienced it so well why need
there be more of this but what it did
was something I didn't expect
um it actually very much kind of expands
on the characters rather than reduces
them I think I had it in my head that if
I'm gonna watch something over the
course of probably eight nine hours
depending on how long each episode is
how could it give me as much detail as a
10 hour video game not that they're that
different and like that
of Intel actually watching it that it
can actually give you a lot more detail
on the characters and their motivations
and where they come from and their
perspectives especially now that we're
not just tied to Joel's perspective
because the TV show is just like one
giant cutscene The Last of Us is a video
game has all of the combat and the
stealth and the tension in between that
really only works when you're playing it
so I love that about it I'm viewing it a
lot more now as an assistance to the
story of The Last of Us than something
that isn't as good so obviously we have
the cold opening uh everything builds up
with Sarah with some things that I like
one to one to the video game which I
think is awesome to see like the spot
where they're in the car and you see the
house burning on the side and it's like
I don't know when you play a video game
you feel like you experience that so
it's not like you're just seeing a
reference it feels a little bit more
personal you're seeing something that
you feel like you lived through an event
that you emphasize empathize with and I
loved seeing like some of those
conversations were one-to-one the same
with Sarah and Joel and they had some in
the first episode that were the same
with alien Joel so it's not like it's
not lit with um references but because
of the way that they're done in this TV
show they actually didn't feel to me
like references what it feels like is
that that dialogue actually was just
perfect or that setting or whatever was
actually just perfect for that
storytelling purpose that they aren't
putting them in there as references or
cameos they're putting them in there
because it is the perfect way to still
to tell this story why would you ever
need to do anything different which
makes it feel a lot less fan servicing a
lot less cheap to me which again was
another thing that I was worried about
the things that are directly the things
that are exactly the same as the video
game don't feel like they're exactly the
same as the video game to appease me
which always makes me feel like cheap
and dirty they feel like they're there
because it was just always the best
option for that line even if sometimes
they're delivered differently which is
actually really cool to see from the
actors as well I think it's also an
incredible opening for people who've
never played the games which I can only
imagine is probably like a not
insignificant portion of this audience
if they had one of the biggest openings
of all time I think the second biggest
on HBO ever
4.7 million people that's incredible so
for anyone who's new it clearly sets up
the kind of very relatable at this point
pandemic setting really it's paced
really well and It's haunting in ways
that I was like how is this going to
translate without being just like tacky
cheap jump scares but then you get that
shot in that first episode with Sarah
standing there with the old lady in the
background twitching and I was like oh
that's how you're gonna do it there are
definitely things that I think will not
translate uh to The Last of Us series if
you aren't playing them there are things
that we do in video games that are
excusable because of gameplay that I
think when you watch them on a TV show
they become a lot more horrific a lot
more disturbing a lot less comfortable
for audiences to watch so I'm really
interested to see what path that goes
down but for the start Sarah's death
obviously plays out very very very
similarly similarly heartbreaking I mean
I think that Pedro Pascal
his performance is incredible to me it
is the essence of Joel the character is
still there you are seeing the same core
the same Foundation he just expresses a
little bit differently even then not
that much in the first episode I'm sure
that'll uh expand as we go forward but I
found it a lot easier again especially
as someone who's friends with Troy to
separate the two my head while I was
watching it at no point ever said that's
not John Miller at no point did I ever
have any issue with disconnecting Pedro
Pascal from Joel I immediately watched
it and was like yep he's that guy which
is always a thing that can be tough when
an actor replaces another actor
especially when you know video games
again I find just like I'm sure it's not
just me to be so personal and intense
because you feel like you had that lived
experience it almost feels like there
are a lot of people who played um the
first Last of Us that like they are
friends kind of I know that sounds
really cheesy but I think that you know
that's the power of video games is that
empathy and so having him replaced with
Pedro Pascal was something that I was
not sure I would be able to take
immediately but nailed it absolutely
perfect I feel very similarly about
um Bella Ramsey uh playing Ellie I feel
like people have been very critical of
her in ways to just kind of suck like
some of it's just kind of boarded on
bullying I don't know I felt like some
of it's been pretty mean to be honest
um really just a lot of people
criticizing the way that she looks like
suggestions that she's not cute enough
or pretty enough to play Ellie which is
I don't Vibe with any of that and I also
have never really felt like actors need
to look the same in video games as they
do in adaptations because you're not
it's not it's just it's about the
character it's about a good performance
it's about a good actress it shouldn't
be about someone looking identical I
don't really feel like that serves the
story and I think she's fantastic as
well I feel like some of her lines are a
little bit different to Ellie but she's
got that same harshness that same sort
of defensiveness that um I really loved
Ellie full when I played it back in the
day because it would have been so easy
to write that character as very hopeless
and needy and very princessy it would
have been so easy to fall into that trap
of having her be just like this perfect
good little girl but she's got attitude
and uh she's got a point to prove and
she's got the world on her shoulders and
I feel like Bella Ramsay's performance
is also fantastic and that's the thing
that really was going to carry this show
because the last of us again the game
stands out for some of the best
performances in video games ever like I
feel like you kind I can't argue that
and especially for such a personal and
brutal and
um heartfelt story of people you know in
a world that is just full of trauma you
have to have fantastic performances and
this show was really only ever going to
be as good as its worst actor I think
the Holocaust is amazing like well Tess
was great I love that they have the
actual voice actress for modeling
playing Marlene she's amazing like just
so happy with all of that and of course
this episode has to do the job like the
one important job of the first episode
is to set up that paternal relationship
between Joel and Sarah to give us
Foundation of where Joel came from and
who he is you know this this Texas man
living with his daughter
the relationship they have
um it gives context to that extremely
important information that will serve
the story going forward of course so we
have that initial setup sorry I'm
jumping around so much so I don't script
these kind of videos like just like
speak from the heart you know and then
we get into you know actual
um apocalyptic stuff happening things on
fire crashes quote unquote zombies
they're not zombies but whatever and
yeah I loved the stuff that was almost
identical like the back of the truck but
um also like very happy with production
value here the way that Boston looked
which I believe is Toronto um dude the
set design is incredible and uh no part
of me ever questioned this world there
was nothing that ever stood out to me I
was thinking that this wasn't like 100
real but just like the explosions the
way that the action is shot is all very
very specific very intimate which I
think is super important it's very easy
to like take a big action sequence and
get crazy with it for a director to like
really you know go all out Michael Bay
think that that's what people want but
when you're telling such an intimate
story really about the relationship
between two people that's really what
the last of us is and that is what this
is set up to be regardless of how much
it it shifts or changes uh throughout
the rest of the season I can't imagine
that they stray from The Last of Us even
the name itself is about it being these
two people really forget the rest of the
survivors that's what the story is it's
two people coming from very complex
places sort of figuring out more about
themselves via each other in a very
sweet way and so having those action
sequences shot in a very intimate way
like all of the stuff with Sarah cameras
are often really tight we're not getting
a lot of outside perspective we're
really seeing a narrow perspective of
how they feel about things while the
world is chaotically growing around them
and it never really Zooms in for too
long in any of that chaos and when it
does kind of lean into that chaos it's
things like setting up again like sort
of who the characters are like Joel
refusing to help a family on the side of
the road and then yeah but we get to the
Sarah death and it is devastating and
heartbreaking all the same so then we
get to the 20 years later
um which is 2023 I believe and
interesting because I believe that that
timeline is different than in the games
if I'm remembering correctly so we get
to Boston quarantine Zone again I think
it looks absolutely incredible the set
design here is amazing we get a very
very fast very efficiently tall detail
of what is happening in this world and
why and you know our intro to Ellie I
think Bella Ramsay's just immediately
like on fire attitude I hope that
everybody who is questioning it
understands like it's hard to find a
good actress her age regardless
and she's very good
and then the two have chemistry together
which is important like you have to do
chemistry tests like there are so many
things that go into making a decision
like this that that I really think I
have a lot of faith in the people who
chose Bella Ramsay but it's also I just
felt like she was fantastic on screen
but yeah then we see obviously Tess and
Marlene as well both awesome hardened
um Marlene being a very sympathetic
terrorist effectively she's still got
moments of vulnerability that are
displayed very well that like make you
more interested in her character and how
she got in this leadership role but
are not um off-putting or too fresh like
a very good balance to her introduction
there I thought and I guess there were
maybe some moments that I felt were
probably a little bit too quick
um not in terms of Marlene but maybe
Tess obviously we saw some introduction
to what our character was doing but we
didn't really get much Insight on
anything that was happening with their
relationship it was very very fast to
introduce us to um
to test we also didn't really get a lot
of context into the quarantine Zone
which I think I maybe would like to see
a little bit more of a little bit more
of the life that Joel is leaving to go
on this journey
um because that's gotta be a lot you
know it's been 20 years we do have to we
have to have had a lot more motivation
than just oh we're not hearing from the
radio tower anymore I feel
um unless we know he was super unhappy
there or something that they did set up
that conflict I'm totally not saying
that they didn't some of it was just
maybe a little bit too fast and that's
just me like
trying to I I think that this episode is
fantastic I think it's so good it's so
so so good so it's not like I I'm even
pointing this out as a fault it's more
that I'm saying here's the thing that I
would have liked to have seen a little
bit more of if that makes sense I'm not
saying like it's a flaw I'm saying more
I'm interested more in the meat of that
like what does this quarantine Zone look
like here like what is his life what is
his relationship with Tess but I don't
doubt that the rest of the show can
build a lot of that out they have a lot
to cover in the first episode and the
first episode is a movie length that's
long and I do feel like you know we got
introduced to the setting incredibly
well the concepts very very well just
some things that I'm like oh interesting
would have liked to have seen more but I
guess that's probably for a show that's
this long old episodes this long like
maybe if we had have gotten more than I
wouldn't feel so strongly about the
pacing and then it wouldn't it wouldn't
have worked and they've made that
decision for a good reason I guess one
thing that I wouldn't have necessarily
done is opened on an interview I've
always been told that it's a bad
storytelling to start something on a
news broadcast or
um an interview that's that I think I
learned that when I was studying writing
at University diversity they go don't do
that it's cheating
and I didn't necessarily feel like that
was needed
um but I suppose it's helpful probably
for the TV audiences who aren't familiar
with the game I'm not really sure but
because it is so fast I also I guess I
do wonder if TV audiences maybe could
have been a little bit lost but I doubt
it I really think they did a fantastic
job with the storytelling here you have
to set up for Joel and Ali we have the
setup for everything to happen with Joel
and we see this this relationship
beginning from a point of
tension distrust contentment maybe even
a little bit of dislike between Joel and
Ellie that is really the core of the
show like I said and the thing that has
to stand out and I think that I already
um I'm very interested to see them so
ultimately review of the first episode I
think it's fantastic I I really really
enjoyed it I was watching it and
afterwards you know credits roll and I
go
wow that's really good TV and again
after like something like Halo even
after watching book of Boba Fett which I
try not to talk about Star Wars on this
channel anymore
I really did not like book of Boba Fett
seeing an IP that I care about handled
with this level of care
on TV it just you know it warms my heart
so well made from top to bottom
beautiful sets
technical Artistry in terms of like how
it's shot paced very very quickly and
clearly very carefully definitely always
extremely engaging there was no part
where I was even close to being bored or
uninterested nothing even slightly
touched on that and even though I've
seen that story before I was still
engrossed in watching it fall out in
this new format so that's a win from me
um so that's how I feel about episode
one let me know what you guys think and
from there like I said I am going to
every Monday night 6 PM PT have a
different group of guests feel free to
suggest people in the comments below I'm
also taking uh suggestions more
specifically on patreon if you're a
supporter there I've already been taking
some guest requests there but I will
have a group of different people
um join me every week to chat about the
episodes live so we can also interact
with you guys in the chat so that'll be
here on YouTube and
um yeah and play which listen we're also
still talking to Troy about the show we
do on the episode that goes up tomorrow
as well if you want to check that out so
yeah I'm just happy it's just really
nice man